[Music]
in many parts of the world rice is the
main grain in fact it is a food staple
for nearly half of the planet's
population native to asia it has been
grown and consumed for thousands of
years but today machines do much of the
harvesting and processing in order to
feed the enormous demand
these perfectly formed kernels of rice
are essentially a crop that has been
allowed to go to seed
after about 150 days of growth the rice
seed is ready for harvest
machinery strips it from the stalks and
also suctions out some of the empty
husks
[Music]
trucks transport the rice to storage
facilities
they empty it into a grated opening at
the receiving pit
the grates filter out some of the larger
stalks and debris
from the pit a chain conveyor moves the
rice up to storage silos and into
warehouses
[Music]
inside the storage facilities fans blow
air through the mountain of rice to
lower the moisture content substantially
[Music]
with the rice sufficiently dried it's on
to the processing plant
here a probe vacuums up samples from
both the front and the back of the
massive truckload
the probe delivers the samples to a lab
a technician first tests the moisture
content to confirm that it's on target
he then transfers batches to a sifting
pan to screen for bugs
he switches on a heat lamp to wake them
up
he shakes the rice and scrutinizes
he also examines the tray underneath for
tiny bugs that may have fallen through
the holes
if he finds just one moth or beetle
the entire 5500 pound truckload of rice
will be rejected
next the rice falls through perforations
in rolling cylinders
screening out the straw which spills
over the side
the next machine sifts out the remaining
straw bits and any weed seed
it also suctions out empty rice husks
they're lightweight and pulled out with
a weak vacuum
finally they remove mud balls
free of contaminants the rice now spills
between two rubber rollers one moving
faster than the other
this shears off the husks
the rice and empty husks then cascade
into another machine
this is a demo version of the actual
production one
weak suctioning pulls out the husks to
separate them from the heavier rice
[Music]
the de-husking process misses a few
kernels so next giant sifting machines
screen out that rice
still in husks it's bigger and doesn't
pass through the holes in the shaking
trays
they dehusk that rice and mix it with
the rest
[Music]
grinding machines now mill the rice to
remove the bran
[Music]
the brand spills out of perforations and
is recovered for use in cattle feed
with the bran removed the rice goes from
brown to white
the final grinding polishes the rice to
give it a pearly sheen
[Music]
this is the unmilled brown rice
and here it is with the brand removed
during milling some race kernels are
damaged
this spinning dimpled cylinder now
separates the broken kernels from the
whole ones
the broken rice kernels fall into the
dimples of the cylinder and from there
into an internal catch pan
they'll be used to make cereal or beer
the whole rice now moves through a color
sorter
computerized cameras analyze it for dark
imperfections and signal air nozzles to
blast them out of the mix
of course there's also a market for
unmilled brown rice
[Music]
now ready for packaging a scraper moves
it across a table and into plastic tubes
below
hot jaws seal the tubes at both ends and
this rice is in the bag
[Music]
brown or white
short or medium-grade
there are plenty of options
[Music]